salut à tous aujourd'hui on vous emmène
en balade sur les routes de notre belle
normandie une balade néanmoins rapide et
sportive à vélo immersion dans le 35ème
tour de normandie ces sports c'est parti
ce soir dans ces sports on parlera de
football avec le tournoi international
u19 la basse normandie accueille pendant
une semaine les jeunes pousses de
l'équipe de france retour également sur
l'ensemble des résultats sportifs de la
semaine
un prologue six étapes pour précisément
1030 et 1,6 km voilà à quoi ressemble et
l'horizon lundi matin pour les 144
coureurs du tour de normandie
un tour qui ressemble une fois n'est pas
coutume un révélateur de talents car sur
les routes normandes ce sont bien les
futurs cracks du vélo mondial les
équipes jeunes des teams professionnels
avant de voir tout ce qui s'est passé
pendant ces sept jours de course avant
de connaître le nom du 35e vainqueur du
tour de normandie
petit détour vers le reste de l'actu
sportive de cette semaine
hier les mondevillaises ont fait parler
la poudre face à calais les joueuses de
romain lhermitte se sont imposés
largement 80 à 60 notamment grâce aux 28
points de courtney love et à une julie
va nous libérer
c'est les playoffs maintenant faut qu'on
gagne tous les matches encore on va
essayer de gagner le plus possible
et voilà on s'en rend pas sa musique et
au classement mondial reste 8e en
water-polo les mares swing d'eronville
jouer ce week end à caen leur
demi-finale de n1 avec en ligne de mire
l'accession en élite
les joueuses de yoann paco n'ont pas
failli en venant à bout de nancy limoges
et son humour rugby à présent avec les
joueuses de l'ovalie caennaise
cet après-midi la marche était trop
haute face au leader montpellier défaite
14 à 22
les joueuses de patrick reymond sont
quoi qu'il arrive déjà assuré de se
maintenir en top 8
lourde défaite également pour les
handballeurs de cherbourg en déplacement
à dijon ils se sont inclinés 31 25
au classement pas de changement
cherbourg conserve sa cinquième place
42e édition d'alençon médavy cet après
midi à plus de 3000 inscrits pour cette
course de 15 km 400 entre le centre
ville d'alençon et la croix de médavy en
pleine forêt d'ecouves et surtout un
final à couper le souffle avec une
montée de 5 km enfin on voit la salle
basse normandie a rendu son verdict et
c'est yann eliès qui s'est imposé mais
skipper breton remporté cette sixième
édition qui s'est déroulée autour de
l'île de jersey avec cette victoire il
s'offre également un billet pour la
prochaine solitaire du figaro
de retour à notre fil rouge avec un
invité qui ne passe pas inaperçu la
pluie s'est conviés à la première étape
du tour à quelques minutes du grand
départ certains sont fatalistes d'autres
ont encore un peu d'espoir je reste
positif en me disant que c'est le pire
j'aurai pire on peut en espérant que
demain ce sera meilleur
non non ça serait pas meilleure ben
merci quand même espoir vite douchée car
cette première journée va se transformer
en véritable enfer
dans des conditions dantesques le
peloton va rallier colombelles à
forges-les-eaux 207 km face au vent sous
la pluie et ce jour là le maître des
enfers s'appelle lucas destang le
coureur français s'impose au sprint
après 5h08 de combat contre les éléments
la remontée samedi
enfermé conclu par une belle victoire
donc
donc voilà c'est exceptionnel c'est la
plus belle victoire de ma carrière
la fin de cette première étape sera
également marquée par une chute massive
dans le peloton chute qui va créer la
polémique et une drôle quand gilad le
lendemain matin
en cause le retard comptabilisé pour les
coureurs pris dans la chute de la veille
outre cet imbroglio la deuxième étape ne
restera pas dans les têtes sauf
peut-être celle du belge dimitri claeys
vainqueur à elbeuf
le power verandas willems imposé
s'empare du maillot jaune
un maillot qu'il va garder jusqu'au
matin de l'avant dernière étape car la
journée de samedi va bouleverser le
35ème tour de normandie
dans des conditions une fois de plus
apocalyptique une bande de sept va
s'échapper du peloton et parmi eux alex
peeters
le coureur anglais ne compte que 18
secondes de retard au général et il va
emmener deux compagnons d'échappée vers
la victoire
bah alors se passer une improbable fin
de course à quelques kilomètres de
l'arrivée les trois hommes de tête vont
se tromper de route
alex pieters va même chuté sur la ligne
il termine deuxième mais réussit à
prendre le maillot jaune pour quelques
centièmes
deux hommes en moins d'une seconde
scénario incroyable ce matin au départ
de la dernière étape à torigni sur vire
comme l'an passé ce tour de normandie
2015 va donc se jouer lors de l'ultime
journée dans des conditions météos une
nouvelle fois très difficile l'anglais
alex peeters et le belge dimitri claeys
s'observent
car sur la route qui mène à caen chaque
seconde compte
suspense et tensions cette dernière
étape est contrôlé en permanence par les
deux équipes des favoris lorsque le
peloton arrive à quand rien n'est fait
l'épreuve va donc se jouer dans les deux
derniers kilomètres
scénario hallucinant pendant quelques
instants ces mêmes geert le power bmc
qui s'échappe et qui est virtuel maillot
jaune mais derrière le belge dimitri
claeys revient et termine 2e du sprint
final
claeys en poche mais quelques secondes
de bonifications nécessaires pour
remporter sur le fil ce tour de
normandie
au final on s'est toutes toujours les
bordures sprint va prendre des
bonifications
j'ai des faits réels pour seulement six
petites secondes
dimitri claeys inscrit son nom au
palmarès de ce 35e tour de normandie en
quelques minutes de clôtureront ce 35ème
tour de normandie mais d'abord nous
allons
une page ball une page jeunesse notre
dossier de la semaine est consacrée au
tournoi international u19 de football
organisé chez nous en basse normandie
avec notamment l'équipe de france
regardez
il est 19 heures un soir pas comme les
autres les u19 tricolore ouvre une
nouvelle page de leur histoire
européenne
et cette histoire commence comme souvent
ces derniers temps en basse-normandie
saint lô bayeux et flers voilà les trois
villes hôtes du tour élite la phase
qualificative pour l'euro 2015
il faut donc croire que la
basse-normandie plaît aux instances
dirigeantes de la fifa car en 2009 déjà
c'est elle qui avait été choisie pour
accueillir la compétition
mieux en 2010 et l'euro lui même qui
avait débarqué avec on s'en souvient la
victoire des bleuets devant 20000
spectateurs à d'ornano
c'était vraiment une belle manifestation
ça a été un bon moment et je crois
vraiment dans la mémoire collective des
passionnés de sport quel que soit le
sport c'était quand même une compétition
européenne pour les bleus et la
normandie c'est donc un peu une seconde
maison
ce qui n'a pas empêché un départ poussif
pour les joueurs de patrick gonfalone
jeudi face à l'azerbaïdjan ils se sont
imposés 2-0 dans un match complètement
verrouillé sans espaces sans solution
les petits bleus s'en sont alors remis
au talent de l'équipe kinsley koeman
le joueur de la juventus de turin a dû
attendre la dernière demi heure de jeu
mais s'est finalement offert un doublé
avec la même génération du 16 au 17
on avait bien commencé tourna avec
khatra on n'était pas passé donc elles
font qu'on va se concentrer absolument
qu'on va ne le prochain mois ge est
justement le prochain match c'était hier
à flers et comme face à l'azerbaïdjan le
départ a été plus que compliquée
dominés par des danois mieux organisés
il faut attendre la 42e minute de jeu
pour voir la première occasion française
conclue par ce héros du racisme les
danois vont ensuite aidé les bleus et
dans leur tâche avec l'expulsion à
l'heure de jeu de jonas gamer ce qui va
profiter à ses roues guirassy encore lui
quelques minutes plus tard score final 2
0 pour s'offrir un voyage en grèce cet
été et participé à l'euro il suffira aux
petits bleus de ne pas perdre mardi face
à l'angleterre
petit détour maintenant sur l'agenda
sportif de la semaine prochaine
en football déplacement périlleux pour
le stade malherbe les cannes et iront à
nantes défiait les canaris pour le
compte de la 31e journée dimanche à 17
heures semaine chargée pour les filles
de mondeville déplacement à tarbes
mercredi 1er avril avant de recevoir
lyon le samedi suivant
voilà le tour de normandie s'achever
avec la victoire finale du belge dimitri
claeys prochain grand rendez vous
cycliste dans notre région c'est dès la
semaine prochaine avec la classique
paris camembert ces sports c'est terminé
pour cette semaine
et moi je vous dis à très vite femme qui
reçoit le maillot vert